there's no chance I'll eat that meatball
I don't know what wag you is I'm not
putting it in my body hello and welcome
to every damn day so they were gonna be
playing a game called pile of cash
versus expensive food today we have $100
cash on the table or three $100
meatballs and we also have a special
guest Chris de Stefano who is an hour
special out tonight the new white is
kind of a little bit like all right you
know it's like this hipster person that
loves themselves yoga class is free
cheeks racial harmony we're gonna make a
difference it's like you're gonna get
shot okay listen I know you're having a
good time with yourself but you're on a
unicycle okay so yeah just listen have a
good time
knock yourself out but you're coming
down my block on a wheel so we take that
as a direct threat you know say I'm like
yeah all right let's meet our meatball
we're seeing a $100 Kobe beef meatball
it consists of Wagyu beef garlic onions
eggs parsley basil Parmesan cheese and
bread crumbs and then they stuff it with
frog rock and truffle cheese and then
they put it it's in a rich shallot and
champagne cream sauce oh and top it with
more black truffle that is a pricey
meatball besides I think that's a joke I
stole from the video yeah no that's a
pricey meatball spicy meat yeah yeah
Chris what is your experience with
meatballs my special is called size 38
way with meatballs I like them I like
only cow meatballs though I don't like
when they put all that other I
don't want to build me a wall or a
chicken meatball or two if it's gotta be
from it you have to kill a cow and mash
it up and put it in a ball and dip it in
sauce and then I'll either yeah well I
mean today be a very special cat we have
Wagyu beef in the meatball
what that means what are you I think it
just means it's like very expensive yeah
it's like when they massage the cows
right is that your baby yeah that's what
they say when you massage Japanese is it
Japanese it sounds Japanese I don't know
moments we're gonna we're gonna put a
timer on and we're gonna debate how
we're gonna vote if four people choose
the meatball then that means one person
gets $100 it could be the other way
around now if five people choose the
meatball then that means that we must
destroy the $100 we set it on fire
isn't it a federal offense yeah I guess
so I don't know it's part of the rules I
don't make the rules we can choose to be
criminals or not yes and now if five
people choose the cash we have to put
the meatballs in a trash bin and urinate
on them look at these beautiful
meatballs this is $300 worth of
meatballs and we have the truffles on
top let's start that timer Chris how are
you feeling right now with the meatballs
there's no chance I'll eat that meatball
number one it has no sauce nobody -
that's not so that's I don't know what
that is that's it's not it has to have
red sauce number two I don't know what
wag you is I'm not putting it in my body
great I know that I saw I could tell by
the guy who I thought was making it he
looked too healthy if your meatballs for
me and that grandma has to beef up
somebody has to have one hip and there's
no way they put love and energy into
that I don't I don't I'm not gonna
disrespect my grandmother by eating that
one bag that's all that's not be yes
he's gonna eat it I think you're I think
he's going for percent well I have high
cholesterol okay but okay when is the
the ones the next time you're gonna eat
$100 meatball there's no other
opportunity that you would buy yourself
$100 meatball unless we bet on ourselves
and our success yeah I mean even if I'm
rich I don't think I'm gonna do that
because then I'll feel like an asshole
yeah you will you wanted to buy those
Crocs by what's-his-name
you know what that's dick that's way
different than this that's this is
better Natasha how are you feeling about
this right now well I just want to win
you know what I'm saying uh I'll tell
you in just one second what goodness all
right so I think for sure Hannah's gonna
choose money last time she tricked me
she pretended to love the food she chose
the money yes I know this time she's
gonna do the money ain't no way she's
gonna choose that and then I wrote two
J's I think both of you are gonna choose
I think Jordan you're definitely gonna
choose meatball so I think he's gonna
choose a meatball - yes but also it's
got foie gras in it and that's very
unethical to eat that's when they stuff
a duck with a bunch of stuff and then
they like what he pig's eye
I can eat bacon that's about it I will
need duck and I don't eat I don't eat I
don't eat veal and I've never had a pork
chop pork chop while why are you
choosing these animals in particular I
don't know
but it's not even the whole thing it's
just the back yes you read it down and
you cannot change your vote and once
you've written it down we're gonna show
to camera survivor style Whoopi fix
[Music]
okay I have the results in my hands and
I'm gonna hand them off to Chris so Joe
this is they go let's sing the Oscar
goes to moonlight the winner is
we got three cash and two meatballs yeah
yeah I mean you know you could see who I
mean like it yeah I feel like I lost
yeah okay you picked cash yeah I went
with cash because I thought people might
choose in the ball this time that I
wanted to get a hundred bucks yeah Chris
went meat boy this looks like that's
like 33 bucks to me all right
$18 okay sure the mushrooms are good I
need 21 dollars higher you guys liking
this is this okay hundred dollars worth
of food no what's your opinion I like it
you like it yeah but do you like it a
hundred dollars you know my money I made
a bad joke fine hundred out here you do
it nice but I know you know one do the
math thank so much to Chris for joining
us his special size 3/8 waist is tonight
so check that out and check us out on
twitter on extra damn day
[Music]